Дарині - 14.
Понад пів року вона прожила в окупації
в рідній Голій Пристані, що на Херсонщині.
У вересні разом з родиною дівчина виїхала до Одеси.
Батьки швидко влаштувалися на роботу, а сама Дарина
відновила навчання в школі і записалася на професійні курси,
які в Одесі запустили спеціально для дітей-переселенців.
Взагалі я прийшла на кулінарний курс, аби краще навчитися готувати, аби більше навчитися готувати.
Також на цих кулінарних я дізналася, що є ще багато курсів.
З них усіх зробили курс лідерства, там, де ораторські здібності кращими стають.
Від цих ораторських здібностей йдуть ще курси французької та англійської. Це також дуже прикольно.
Спеціальні професійні курси для дітей в Одесі запустив благодійний фонд "Добрий Самарянин",
який майже тридцять років допомагає дітям-сиротам, пенсіонерам, а тепер - і переселенцям,
яких в Одесі нині близько 60 тисяч. Для них щоденно працює гуманітарний штаб,
а волонтери - організовують творчі майстерні для людей будь-якого віку.
Проте фонд окремо вирішив приділити увагу саме дітям - найбільш вразливій категорії ВПО.
Підлітків-переселенців навчають кулінарній, перукарській та манікюрній справі.
Була ідея соціалізувати дітей, дати їм можливість познайомитися один з одним, а також навчитися професії.
Це така допрофесійна підготовка.
Зараз ми хочемо запустити школу професій для якомога більшої кількості підлітків.
Не лише в Одесі, а й Одеській області.
Нині на безкоштовній основі в нас навчатимуться протягом пів року тридцять дві дитини.
Також відкривається ще один напрям "Мудрий тесля". Це навчання з різьби по дереву для хлопчиків.
Додатково відкривається курс лідерства, а також курс з вивчення англійської й французької мов.
Кожен зі слухачів курсів прийшов на навчання зі своїми цілями й бажаннями.
Ми розпитували в наших учнів: навіщо вони тут, яка їхня мета.
І насправді дивовижно те, наскільки різні в них цілі: хтось хоче робити мамі манікюр,
а хтось хоче опанувати майбутню професію. Всі абсолютно різні.
Разом з Дариною кулінарну майстерність опановує й 13-річний Олег.
Що таке війна - знає  з шести років.  Саме стільки йому було, коли навесні 2014-го
рідний Краматорськ захопили проросійські терористи.
Маленький Олег був свідком запеклих боїв у місті аж до самого звільнення Краматорська 5 липня.
Однак у 2022-му російські ракети таки вигнали його з рідного дому.
Кожну ніч стабільно були прильоти, почало звужуватися кільце над моїм містом.
І ми вирішили, що все: якщо ми не виїдемо, то, мабуть, все буде, як у Маріуполі.
Про курси професій Олег довідався від мами, але рішення записатися на них ухвалював самостійно.
Мені мати показала в Телеграм-каналі повідомлення, що ось іде набір на кулінарний курс, безкоштовно.
Я вирішив: а чому б не почати саморозвиватися?
Вирішив, поїхав, мені там сподобалося, я почувався нормально і вирішив сюди знову приїхати сьогодні.
Я вирішив шукати нове життя. Насправді я зараз знайшов друзів.
Саме така соціальна складова, коли підлітки переселенці завдяки професійним курсам знаходять нових друзів,
украй важлива для дітей.
Наприклад,  я ходила до цього курсу ще на одні курси, то там також знайшла достатньо друзів.
І тут просто знайшла собі подругу найкращу.
Для нас дуже важливо, щоби була увага до дітей, така психологічна підтримка.
Тому що діти дуже вразливі, більшість із них виїхали з окупації.
Дуже тонкі такі натури. І ми хочемо, щоб наші зустрічі для них були підтримкою, натхненням та мотивацією.
Підлітки можуть обрати будь-який курс, або ж поєднувати навчання одразу за кількома спеціальностями.
Серед викладачів - провідні спеціалісти Одеси, які на волонтерських засадах
допомагають переселенцям здобувати нові знання та віру в свої сили.
Приміром, один із викладачів курсу перукарської майстерності - власник мережі барбершопів Євген Д'яченко.
Чому ми займаємося цією справою й чому навчаємо взагалі?
От ви бачили, що учениця була. Їй цікаво й вона просто прийшла подивитися.
Наша задача першочергова – це впровадження нашої культури в маси.
Хочеться приєднувати всіх до нашої культури барберингу.
Приєднувати до того, щоб всі слідкували за собою.
Серед слухачів курсу - 15-річна Дар'я з Сєвєродонецька.
Рік тому дівчина закінчувала дев'ятий клас і планувала розпочати професійне навчання на перукаря.
Але почалася повномасштабна війна, і замість того, щоб готуватися до вступу, Дар'я рятувала своє життя.
Тепер дівчина нарешті має змогу втілити свою мрію в життя.
Я з дитинства хотіла стати перукарем та довго планувала, довго хотіла,
довго просила батьків, щоб вони все ж таки дозволили піти після 9 класу, а не після 11, як вони хотіли.
Я їх вмовила, але почалася війна...
Протягом навчання підлітки здобуватимуть практичні навички, працюючи в гуманітарному центрі.
Приміром, усю їжу, що готуватимуть на кулінарних курсах, роздаватимуть нужденним.
А перукарські здібності діти зможуть випробувати, роблячи зачіски пенсіонерам, які приходять до благодійного фонду по допомогу.
Також невдовзі стартує курс зі столярства, який триватиме три роки.
Долучитися до школи професій можуть всі охочі діти-переселенці.
Усе, що потрібно - згода батьків та довідка про статус внутрішньо переміщеної особи.